yeah so if you're gonna get a Coke or
Diet Coke at a restaurant get a water
too and pound that water before you
drink that just so you can just balance
out whatever the [__] you're drinking
and my thing to that is just no
[Music]
all right here's one for Nick since he's
a big Health freak I'm not dude
I'm fake you like uh diet sodas
oh [__] sometimes me I got the Nick
coming at me hey I like them sometimes
dude he has a little bit of Relic but
who who drinks diets he does I drink
juice I drink zeros I have two zeros
Pepsi's aren't they like worse peps is
weird
I like both I like I can't do it hurts
my stomach hurts oh you got a stomach
ache I mean I don't do like sodas in
general I'm glad advertising worked on
you because your taste buds are [__]
so um yeah diet sugars taste gross to me
none of you guys drink diet sodas also
no wonder why he doesn't do bougie food
either
I would taste it but I realized it gives
me headaches
dinosaurs do yeah but I like I like the
way it's I mean I don't like the way it
tastes but I like maybe maybe it's
because your brain is broken dude yeah
maybe it's because you had too many diet
Red Bulls Bart I saw you [__]
sneaking one after lunch [__]
Diet Cokes the diet ginger ale wow the
diet Dr Pepper that's what activates
your [__]
yeah
Colleen liked it she liked it if she
laughed it's okay it's so stupid it
activates your [__] your vagina got
activated yeah
so when you're in is that true by the
way is that true
no [__] damn it [__] everyone got quite
like I got you Bart
was like he's my boss he's my boss
Mark says gotta support the boss all
right when you're dealing with a client
right and the client's like I need to
lose weight what can I change in my diet
do you suggest diet sodas like later on
the line if they really feel like they
need yeah they're like I gotta have code
like dude yeah I'll say all right that's
an alternative that you could use but
then again it's like depending on how
they feel about artificial sweeteners is
like the whole other argument
because that's a that's a thing that
like some people are weary about
but at the same time it's like it asked
like I think Aspartame is like one of
the the most it's like the most studied
uh artificial sweetener and there's a
lot of people that
that are right in the middle on yeah
it's bad for you versus it's like good
for you oh well it's like it's like it's
neutral but neutral it's a neutral
effect in your body it's totally neutral
it's not good yeah well I know about the
report that just came out damn it yeah
I'm trying to beat your ass I heard
about it I mean the report is that
within a month uh the World Health
Organization is gonna classify aspartame
as being possible carcinogenic
carcinogenic yeah dude what isn't tea
carcinogenic what the [__] are you
talking about there are a lot of things
classified under here but the main
reason why this is a big uh deal is that
it's gonna drastically change the uh
diet food market like the industry
because now they just can't they just
won't use that anymore yeah but I think
a lot of a lot of companies they don't
just use aspartame like they use
sucralose Stevia Stevia is a bunch of
them but even then like I think a lot of
people were especially like all the the
nutrition scientists they talk about how
Stevia is not even like that well
um researched compared to aspartame yeah
what about the other one is it like
Agave or whatever that was pretty that
still has that still has calories though
it's it's still like oh it's not an
empty it's just from a different like
it's natural and a lot of people a lot
of people use that like oh because it
comes from
it comes from it's naturally like like
Stevia oh it comes from a plant so it's
natural I mean cane sugar is natural you
know right honey is [__] natural
exactly shouldn't probably eat it every
[__] minute of the day yeah exactly
yeah right but it's like the seed oils
but a lot of people will like using
honey to sweeten their coffee or tea or
whatever versus sugar because there's
like oh it comes unprocessed yeah but
it's like everyone has like weird um
they got like weird loopholes huh yeah
but the I think the nutrition space they
like to they like to pair this food
versus this food and yeah they like to
see people do Nick what's a superfood
for fucksake
anything with a bunch of nutrients right
yeah micronutrients high in broccoli
I guess I don't know I just don't think
there's any [__]
superfoods really that doesn't exist
super food is that a buzzword I think
that's what I'm saying I think it's more
about a healthy diet versus you need to
eat these Foods all the time I think
that's what it comes down to so uh all
right step in dude what do you gotta say
I like hearing you like date your own
gray that's why
bail me out Mark now everything he said
I think like the way that people like to
view things is they like to go let's put
this thing in a vacuum and really
analyze it where where it's like the
whole thing like are you getting some
sunlight too with like how much sugar
are you eating how much activity what is
your stress levels like are you having
an insanely Immaculate diet but then you
put down like 500 beers at night you
know it's like what's the whole
enchilada you gotta look at all of it
but during covet wasn't the who kind of
like saying like hey don't focus on like
all that other stuff focus on like uh
the vaccine and things like that yeah
yeah stay indoors don't worry about
vitamin D or nothing like that don't go
on walks because you could spread it I
think that's that's probably why
whenever I read an article that says oh
the world health or like even just
seeing it I already go oh they don't
know what the [__] I hate the way I feel
now about them yeah me too this is gonna
probably be [__] you also have to
look at how people jump like create
their conclusions too you know because
especially with certain research studies
anybody could cherry pick a study saying
like this is bad for you because of this
this causes that and by the way everyone
will with their agendas they will
definitely and even in this article like
one of the things it's all so what
should you do if you drink
um aspartame sodas it says consider
switching to regular Coke
but also and what about water because
they don't want to they don't want to
lose a customer they don't want to [__]
over the corporate partner absolutely
like switch to the thing you switched
out of yeah yeah but um it's interesting
because you're gonna buy some Coca-Cola
merchandise instead yeah right by some
birds buy some coke hats right like
drink
um like Coca-Cola from a Coca-Cola glass
a fish or glass that's the thing that's
interesting is they are saying like
still even if this is gonna happen it
doesn't mean that aspartame causes any
of these things it just means that it's
linked to many cases in which people had
developed a disorder and illness and
that was an element of their lifestyle
that's what it shows even like you know
like yeah if you go to like a Denny's or
any diner and they have you know like
sugar packets yeah and then any other
like sweet and lows and whatever when
you pull it out on the back it says is
banana cause cancer in my sort of bro in
my apartment building in Los Angeles
it's like hey being in this parking
structure is known to not cause cancer
and I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about like chemicals Here is
known to cause all kinds of cancers and
leukemias anyways all right see you
later enjoy your day anyways pay your
rent on time yeah what the [__] are you
talking about hey what part of it I'm
not licking the wall here
one of the interesting angles behind why
this is happening is that it's supposed
to have the intention of
bolstering more research to aspartame to
exonerate it from the list does that
make sense it's like you want to make it
uh kind of in the gray zone or in the
danger zone so that people try to find
ways to make it safer it was
it was there in the 8 in the 80s and
then it got weirdly exonerated in the
90s probably because of money and then
like now it's back in the danger zone
just like tea coffee eggs cholesterol
yeah wine but like coffee and tea like
anything caffeine related keeps going
back and forth between being good for
you being bad for you being good for you
in small measures having I mean I I
don't think there's like a one size fits
all for anybody even vitamins they say
they've said like going back and forth
you probably are just like gonna grow an
excess amount on your tailbone because
you have like excess vitamins and they
don't know where nothing your body
doesn't know what to do with it so it
flushes it to one point yeah so you grow
a tail that's [__] we already have a
tailbone right which vitamin is that I
want that but you could find a claim for
anything but they've said that like the
tailbone has extended in some people
because of over vitamin use
dude yeah yeah it is one of the worst
X-Men's ever but that's why like
sometimes I do like the kind of um like
the Bro approach where it's just like me
just give people like some tips and one
of the tips that like because like if
you follow the science it's actually
really hard to like to keep up with it
because it's not a realistic lifestyle
but a very easy tip is that people
always recommend is whatever drinks you
like to drink drink the same amount of
water yeah so if you're gonna get a Coke
or Diet Coke at a restaurant get a water
too and pound that water before you
drink that just so you can just balance
out whatever the [__] you're drinking
and my thing to that is just no yeah and
a lot of people do that a lot of people
go I don't want to do that I'm going to
do what I want to do and that yum yum in
my tummy no I'm not gonna do that okay I
used to work at Giant Rockets these
people a lot of people would drink like
three four Diet Cokes in one sitting
just like hot like they're just sucking
them down sucking them down bro what do
I do with red bulls while we're here
what the [__] we're sucking them now
baby I can do that with Coke Zeros
though yeah I can too but at the same
time it's like what is it about Coke
Zero that's so different than Coke for
you it just tastes different than diet
it tastes like [__] the taste I like it
because it tastes like [__] what you
like I don't think it tastes like caca
you like Coke Zeros taste better than
regular Coke I do but I think I think
it's because I'm more accustomed to it
in a way you get addicted to it I think
you do yeah for sure like Pepsi Zero I'm
100 you do a little dopamine here yeah
it's almost like it just becomes habit
after a while it's not even I don't even
know I'm drinking it yeah I like I like
sodas but then because of the calories I
drink diet soda but if I was had the
crazy metabolism then I would drink
regular soda could taste way better yeah
but you like the diet I like have done
it for so long that now yeah it's too
sweet for me to drink Regular Show
dessert it's like eating ice cream I
can't eat sweets anyway I don't eat
sweets ever like give me the [__]
dulled [__] every time give me give me
these um sodium stuff yeah I'll stay
away from sugar all together same thing
happened to me with mocha Frappuccinos I
used to drink them religiously growing
up and then uh I when I did keto I
started drinking black coffee yeah and
then when I went back to try to drink a
mocha I can't [__] sip it for one
second yeah I can't even finish the soda
it destroys my mouth even as a kid I
could I'd go around the neighborhood and
get Halloween candy just give it to my
brothers because like I don't give a
[__] dude I pound like four butter
fingers right now same anything anything
with peanut butter and chocolate
if I have one I'll fall asleep dude I
like big you fall asleep from peanut
butter from sugar oh it makes you have
that effect okay yeah so next month
you're gonna have to think of a new uh
diet plan for your clients man yeah
we'll figure it out how about you just
let them like be why you gotta tell them
what to do
yeah and they're like stop telling me
what to do all the time and I'm like
sorry man I'm sorry like why do you want
people to change like you're gonna not
have a customer anymore I just tell
people you know just trying to get to
sleep every night that's all try to get
to sleep and go get some steps in that's
it you know they always say you make
money from treatments not from curing
people that's right and neck done is a
[__] A Millionaire because of that
he's the Kaiser of that if you teach a
man to buy the fish from you you could
always sell them
that's how it goes
[Music]